okay so today we have two specific races
that I'm going to talk about for 2020
where we really have extraordinarily of
inspiring I guess I would call them
opportunities to take down some of the
most prominent and toxic Republicans in
the Senate yesterday I told you that
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
has a challenger after later on in the
show I'll talk to you a little bit more
about that race but first today
totally terribly toxic Trump tool about
that Lindsey Graham has an opponent and
the opponent has raised a
record-breaking amount of money his name
is Jamie Harrison he has raised 1.5
million dollars to challenge Lindsey
Graham in South Carolina for his Senate
seat and if you haven't been paying
attention to Lindsey he has become even
more unhinged under Donald Trump on
Leasing one of an Unleashed mother one
of the most cartoonish and embarrassing
tirades that maybe I've ever seen during
the confirmation hearing of Supreme
Court justice Brett Kavanaugh remember
when this went down if you wanted an FBI
investigation you could have come to us
what you want to do is destroy this
guy's life hold this seat open and hope
you win in 2020 you've said that not me
you've got nothing to apologize for
when you see soda Meyer and cake and
tell them that Lindsey said all because
I voted for them I would never do to
them what you've done to this guy this
is the most unethical sham
since I've been in politics that was
real life that was not part of some
poorly scripted political drama or
reality show and a faux reality show it
would be really great to remove Lindsey
Graham and Jamie Harrison conceivably
could make that happen now let's I
always am realistic with you in these
races I don't do the thing where I
pretend that someone pulling one percent
really has a shot at winning in the
presidential primary and I'm not going
to BS you here either
Jamie Harrison is way behind he's raised
1.5 million dollars but Lindsey Graham
has nearly five million dollars or had
five million dollars in the bank at the
of the first quarter of the year and
they're still calculating their second
quarter totals so he may have three four
three or four times as much money as
Jamie Harrison and money matters in our
political system as you know but this is
one of the strongest candidates in
recent history to really have a shot at
taking out such a prominent Republican
senator bado had a shot with Ted Cruz in
Texas ultimately didn't happen
Jamie Harrison is admittedly like many
of these Southern Democrats basically a
centrist establishment guy but given the
circumstances that's okay because we'd
be much better off with Jamie Harrison
than with Lindsey Graham particularly in
a state like South Carolina
Jamie Harrison is a top official for the
Democratic National Committee he's
former chairman of the South Carolina
Democratic Party he's an establishment
guy I mean there's no doubt about it but
Lindsey Graham is just terrible and the
polls are pointing to an uphill battle
Graham has a big lead in the polls as of
right now but okay we still have a while
let's see what we can do and as I said
before yesterday talking about the Mitch
McConnell Challenger in Kentucky the key
is that even if Jamie Harrison doesn't
defeat Lindsey Graham in the end even if
Amy McGrath doesn't ultimately take out
Mitch McConnell in 2020 getting the
Republican Party to have to spend a
bunch of money defending incumbents in
red states makes it more difficult for
them to win other seats because of
limited money that they obviously have
and that's a very good thing and people
have been writing to me about Lindsey
Graham saying even though it goes
against our principles on the Left
shouldn't the left be targeting Lindsey
Graham for being gay because Republicans
don't like it and they might vote him
out I totally disagree with that
strategy number one it's below us to
stoop to that level okay we don't think
there's anything wrong with being gay so
why would we target another candidate
because they are I don't know if Lindsey
I don't know what took to what level of
how publicly Lindsey Graham is gay um
but I don't think it's a good idea for
Democrats to be doing this because it's
just the wrong thing to do and there's
nothing wrong with being gay but more
importantly I also don't think it would
work the right claims to be about family
values but when it comes down
they voted for Trump who was accused 15
times or more of sexual assault the
mistresses the entire thing they don't
actually care they're not gonna vote for
a Democrat most of them anyway and in
the same way
yeah the anti-gay religious right in
South Carolina I get it but they don't
actually care if the alternative to
Lindsey Graham is voting for a Democrat
because this is sport to them they see
this as wins and losses losses period
it's below us and it's wrong to start
using Lindsey Graham's sexual
orientation against him and by the way
it also wouldn't be useful so that's
what's going on with Lindsey Graham a
little bit later on in the program I
want to update you about what's going on
in Aimee McGrath's challenge of
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell in Kentucky the fundraising
numbers are stunning for Amy McGrath but
that's coming up a little bit later make
sure that you are following the show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
on instagram at david pakman I recently
posted a behind-the-scenes shot of what
the studio here looks like what I'm
looking at while I'm taping the show
follow me at David Pakman on Instagram
to see that and much much more quick
break as they always are and back right
after this if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video to
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video